girl he's so fine that's a lot of
laundry creative freedom comes from the
embracement of constraints around us do
you use Twitter or vine of course you do
you're totes popular what should monix
one and everyone knows you love sending
snapchats of your jump to your bro bros
and then the dick on my face isn't there
you may think you're just fooling around
with your friends but you're actually
engaging in a very of-the-moment medium
of communication a six-second format the
short form content 140-character is what
really says is that we continue to snack
on information that's been hub
cheeseburger a network of humor websites
like failblog i can has cheezburger and
know your meme if anyone knows anything
about the importance of short form
content it's this guy the growth in how
we consume information has come from not
sitting down and serious you know
consumption of media but really in
background noise in this ambient
information that we gather and content
is trying to compete with that World Cup
points to the late philosopher media
guru Marshall McLuhan and once
pronounced the medium is the message for
me the form factors message the idea
that the device that is in your hand
actually impacts the type of content
that we clean for it if you're looking
at a tiny little device in your hand
you're not going to watch a lot of big
feature films on it because you don't
have the attention span because you're
upside in an environment meaning we
would almost never watch Batman on our
cell phone but we would watch bad dad on
fine it's time to get out
but if we're spending all our time
watching short videos and reading 140
character tweets aren't we losing our
ability to pay attention so what really
is happening is the annals analogy I use
is that we used to eat deep dish pizza
all the time Nick small compressed heavy
that's attention right thick attention
what's happened now is that we use a lot
of thin crust attention which is that
things are spread out over a larger
surface area because we cannot consume
media over a long horizon of every day
of our lives however the thick parts
haven't gone away we still use some of
that time but in comparison to the all
of attention that we're spending it's
smaller oh it's too hot for business
creative freedom comes from the
embracing of constraints around us it is
not that we have an open field that we
can be absolutely creative anytime you
want it is that creatively come from
breaking a rule breaking through a
format breaking through some restriction
that you have on yourself being naked
now rockers office you okay therefore
these six second videos are gonna create
some of the most amazing content in our
generation